I'm Eddie Brock I'm a reporter now I
always seem to find myself questioning
something the government may not be
looking at I found something really bad
I have been
look around the world who do you see
a planet on the brink of collapse human
beings are disposable like man and
symbiote combined this is a new race
near species the higher life-form
what do you want upon me
[Applause]
we cannot just hurt people
we have a deal i clear so many tracks
from the little time
to that power it's not completely awful
you have no idea how much you're scaring
me right now
and you just might survive guys you do
not want to do this trust me
oops
we'll always come at a cost
[Music]
you will be this honest wigglin
faithless people going down the street
[Music]
oh I have a parasite yeah neighbors
chant hey everybody its charlie we got
to break down this new venom footage as
you could tell it's pretty much the
comic-con footage they showed off with
Polish CG it looks way different from
the original trailer like even his
tongue in this one shot here already
looks a lot better than the last time
the whole idea here is them just showing
off what the symbiote can do if you're
brand new to the channel be sure to
subscribe to get all the videos there's
a new round of that infinity war blu-ray
giveaway - all you have to do to enter
is be a subscriber and leave a comment
on the video even the voice of the
symbiote sounds a little bit different
it sounds a little more identifiably Tom
Hardy at this point before it did kind
of sound like somebody different I
thought it was Tony Todd when we first
started getting a full body shot so you
see there is no spider symbol but there
is a discernible white veiny pattern
that might evolve throughout the film
like this is a little bit better than
the CG in the last trailer I imagined by
the time we get to the next trailer
it'll look even more polished there are
three or four new really important
symbiote shots in this - there's the
expanded version of the one that we saw
ending the last trailer where he comes
up off the bike we are venom it's
completely different dialogue it's him
talking about eating all the various
organs this sort of the companion shot
at the end where the symbiote bites the
head off that mugger oh sorry I have a
parasite is he just casually walks out
the shot that proceeds this shot right
here where it looks like he actually
gets chased off the bike he gets all of
his bones broken
but the symbiote heals them right away
and then a couple of shots throughout
the trailer - where he uses it as a
shield to stop all those bullets when
he's in the building trying to protect
his girlfriend then full-blown shots of
the riot symbiote so that's actually the
one that they're bonding to this person
here at the beginning you see a much
better shot of it in the container here
when they first find it it's meant to be
silver even though there's a little bit
different from the comics they just
wanted to distinguish it from the Venom
symbiote because during the lethal
protector storyline when they created
the five offspring of the Venom symbiote
to create those other ones that he had
to take down it was actually forced
offspring in the way the director
explained the new backstory of the
different symbiotes in this film is that
there
is a pre-existing relationship from the
Clint are where they come from their
alien planet so when they're making
their bargain he's like what do you want
me for in the Venom symbiote says you'll
soon find out it wants to take down the
riot symbiote it needs Eddie's help to
do that
so Eddie's this investigative reporter
he's trying to take down Carleton Drake
because he's a dirtbag in the life
foundation but on the other side of that
coin the Venom symbiote wants to take
down the villain of the film which is
the riot symbiote who you see jump into
a bunch of different hosts during the
trailer so ultimately is actually
Carleton Drake that's going to wheel the
riots symbiote at the very end of the
film when you see them ripping each
other apart here this is closer to the
end of the film that's supposed to be
Carleton Drake this in the riot symbiote
the thing about venom you know
post-credits theory I think that he's
gonna be the stinger in that during this
fight here one of the symbiotes will
actually reproduce the little bit that
gets like sliced off and becomes another
symbiote in its own right will be the
carnage symbiote so I'm guessing you
know venom probably victorious at the
end of the film I'm hoping that it's the
Venom symbiote like the comics because
carnage is the offspring of venom but
the way they're presenting the Riots
symbiote is that it's like pure driven
crazy so it almost feels like they might
change that a little bit so don't be
surprised if carnage ends up being the
offspring of the riot symbiote just
remember that they're changing the
backstory the symbiotes how they get to
Planet Earth there's no discernable
spider-man in this equation which is why
he doesn't have the spider-man symbol on
his chest
it's sort of their way of tiptoeing
around that MCU weirdness like I said
you know big long-run theory is that
they're just trying to wait and see how
this does in real life the interesting
thing too is that the week that this
comes out it has no natural competition
at the box office so there's actually a
pretty good chance that this movie does
pretty well that was originally going to
be that Andy Serkis Moakley movie but
then Netflix bought it so it's not gonna
get a theatrical release they'll just
release it on Netflix so there's no
other big movies coming out the week
that this comes out so we'll see how
that helps it but just let me know what
you think of the look of the symbiote so
now that you get the full body shot of
venom or at least a more polished
version of it I'm sure by the time the
movie comes out it'll look even better
and the look of the riot symbiote now we
have more context for what this scene is
where the office gets cleared is
basically the riots symbiotes just
lashing his blades out chopping all
these people's heads off this shot here
of the symbiotes actually talking to
Eddie is what I was talking about when I
posted my Comic Con video so that it
becomes a little more visually engaging
when Tom Hardy is talking to the
symbiote because it talks to him inside
his head and this type of shot is right
out of the comics too like the symbiote
has its own will it needs
Eddie to survive because that's how all
symbiotes work it's the same thing with
the riot symbiote - so we'll get a
little bit more of the story in the next
big trailer originally it was just meant
to be a really cool black costume for
spider-man then later writers tried to
expand the symbiote cannon and give it a
little bit more depth but like I said
this big fight here with them slicing
the crap out of each other just ripping
each other to shreds I think is the path
to the carnage symbiote being born from
one of these two getting the
post-credits stinger setting up the
sequel because the director did say that
they wrote a special sequel moment at
the end of this film like they are
intending there to be a venom - whatever
they end up calling that what'll happen
is there's a whole bunch more infinity
war blu-ray bonus features and deleted
scenes I'll be doing a video for one of
those necks that should post the next
couple of hours
congratulations to the latest giveaway
winner from my last big video Erik kill
monger please email me on the back end
of my channel so I can get your contact
details click here for the infinity war
blooper reel and click here for that
deleted guardians of the galaxy scene
thank you so much for watching everybody
stay awesome I'll see you guys tonight
[Music]